the cicada situation is out of control
oh good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
when we last visited the garden it was
mostly dirt but now there are zucchini
and sunflowers and these weird Dragon
tongue beans
we've got eggplants and oregano and most
of all we have tomatoes we've got black
cherry tomatoes we've got red cherry
tomatoes we've got these weird guys and
we've also got a metric crap ton of gold
and currants which are tiny little
Tomatoes not much larger than a pea why
did I get so many tomato plants that
make tiny Tomatoes
because I want to eat 211 Tomatoes in a
single sitting one two five this is
gonna take a while I have picked the
tomatoes it took 34 minutes and I am
drenched in sweat let's go inside
actually you know what before we go
picking all of these Tomatoes has made
me want to eat a tomato so I'm going to
hold on mmm delicious I'm gonna have
another one mmm new video title how to
eat 213 Tomatoes in a single sitting
okay so the first thing you're gonna
want to do is lay out your bountiful
harvest and consider all of the time
energy and sweat that went into the
creation of this 900 calories of food
then give thanks to actual farm workers
and then count out exactly 211 Tomatoes
because people on the internet are
sticklers about that stuff so today
we're gonna make panzanella which is
essentially Tomatoes with croutons to
make the croutons you want to preheat
the oven to 350 degrees being careful
not to look at your ghoulish reflection
then take a pan tear up some good bread
put in forest cloves of minced garlic
some olive oil and then I think the
technical term is you just sort of whoo
and then once it's adequately who
should put it in the oven and cook it
for I don't know like 15 minutes then
you're gonna want to chop up all of your
nan goldin currant tomatoes and boom it
was at this point that I realized that
even 211 small Tomatoes is still a lot
of tomatoes I googled can eating too
many Tomatoes kill you and it turns out
probably not but it can turn your skin
orange incidentally you may not think
you like Tomatoes I thought I hated them
until my late 20s but it turned out I
had just never had a good one
tomatoes are one of the very few foods
where the good version is essentially
like a different thing than the bad
version another example would be the
difference between actual lucky charms
and knockoff Lucky Charms let's go back
to the recipe right so you want to put
all your tomatoes in a large bowl add
some balsamic vinegar less olive oil
than I just use some salt and pepper and
who Sh the secret to panzanella is the
crunch of the croutons combined with the
juiciness of the tomatoes so it doesn't
keep well once mixed if you want
leftovers you need to keep them separate
and then add them together as you go so
once your croutons are toasty mix a
handful with a handful of tomatoes put
some sliced basil on the top and you've
got yourself an excellent meal I ate
around 100 Tomatoes at lunch and then
Sara and I split the remaining tomatoes
at dinner three great meals and my skin
did not even turn orange now I just got
to figure out what to do with those
zucchini Hank I'll see you on Friday